. Oh my God, es ist unfassbar! Oh Leute, einen wunderschönen guten Abend, herzlich willkommen in Bochum. Herzlich willkommen zu seinen Stellen in die Folge. Zu Ausseratem die grosse Podcast Ufo-Tour. Es freut mich natürlich sehr, die jetzt viele Fragen haben. Ja, gerade. Wer war, ich meine ernsthafte Frage, wer war noch nie im Star Express und hat jetzt sehr viele Fragen? Sehr viele Arme gehen hoch. Für alle, die es vielleicht nicht wissen, dieses Gebäude wurde extra für unsere Show gebaut.
Vor vier Jahren haben wir die Wünsche geäußert, ist es genauso, wie wir uns vorgestellt haben. Wir können laufen, wir können uns bewegen, wenn wir nur ein bisschen mehr Ausdauer hätten. Wir hatten so eine Bahnspotting-Phase und dann ist diese Idee irgendwie übergeblieben. Und wie gesagt, es wurde jetzt seit 20 Jahren gebaut, dieses Theater, und jetzt rückblickend, wir mögen keine Bahnen mehr, es war nur eine Phase. Aber jetzt ist die Abend fertig. Möglich gemacht von den sehr reichen Menschen, die heute in den Premium-Plätzen sitzen, ja. Ein großer Applaus von den Rängen für die erste Klasse. Es gibt also hier eine klare Zweiklassengemeinschaft auf jeden Fall. Die können sich nämlich hier rumdrehen, wenn man hier so rumläuft. Wohin gegen ihr armen Schlucker, ihr könnt gar nichts machen. Ihr könnt nichts machen, wenn ich hier in eurem Rücken bin. Ihr könnt nichts tun. Wir machen die ganze Show so, das ist jetzt euer Problem. Das ist nicht mein Nacken. Aber wie lustig, weil manchmal weiss man ja irgendwie so wie Steven Spielberg auf Jurassic
Park, okay ja geil, Dinos in der Neuzeit, geil und ich glaube Andrew Webber ist auf Star
Express gekommen, weil wie kriege ich das hin, ein Theater zu bauen mit geilen Drehsesseln.
Ja, das stimmt, ihr könnt euch auch die ganze Zeit drehen, ich habe es vorhin ausprobiert,
mir wurde schon sehr schlecht. Aber man sieht auch, für wen sie sich entscheiden. Ja, das stimmt. Man sieht... Das ist gemein. Das ist gemein. Wir können auch so ein bisschen The Voice machen. Wir singen und ihr dreht euch um, wenn ihr uns gut fühlt. Ihr seht nicht, dass ich tanze, weil ihr euch für Florentine schiedet. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber irgendwie hat man hier so ein bisschen Lust zu singen. Ich weiss nicht, warum, aber dieses... Nee, ich meine es nur ganz allgemein. Wird es um mich dunkel, wird es in mir stehen... Ja, Gott, Stefan kann das ganze Musical auswendig. Ja, da oben habe ich gesessen, da oben habe ich als Kind gesessen. Wow. Im Alter von elf Jahren, nicht da unten, brauchst du dich die Arme hochrecken. Da oben am Billigen Plätzen. Da auf den ganz billigen Plätzen da oben!
Und hab dann, weil, für die Leute, die es nicht wissen, wir sind im Star-Light-Express-Theater, vielen Dank an das Theater, dass wir hier sein dürfen. Es ist ein Musical, wo Züge singen. Ich weiß, viele Fragen bleiben offen. Und das hier ist der Bahnhof, oder? Äh, nee. Also, stell es dir eher vor wie Gleise, zum Beispiel zwischen Hamm und Dortmund und sowas. Ja. So, und wir fahren jetzt hier rum dann als Züge, da oben kann man auch langfahren, will jetzt nicht. Und dann gibt es da eine Hebebühne, die runterfährt und auch noch, quasi kann man auch drüberfahren. Und dann hast du hier so eine Rennstrecke und da fahren dann die Züge lang für die grossen Rennen. Es gibt drei Rennen und am Ende gewinnt die Dampflok als Superior Antriebskraft. Genau, was dieses Stück uns sagen soll, ist nach 50 Jahren immer noch nicht ganz klar, vielleicht finden wir heute versteckte Hinweise oder so. Vor allem, ich habe da oben gesessen und habe dann immer, das ist kein Scheiß, weil es gibt die coole Elektro-Lok, ne, dann habe ich da gesessen und habe den Daumen gedrückt, habe immer gesagt, bitte Elektra, Elektra, in jedem Rennen Daumen gedrückt. Und eigentlich eine unsympathische Figur, also ich habe mich nicht für den Sympath entschieden, eigentlich ein Bösewicht auch, aber ich habe mich für die eigentlich zukunftsträchtigere Antriebskraft entschieden. Ja, ich verstehe. Das freut mich eigentlich. Ich habe damals schon gesagt, die Dampflock ist eigentlich Sympathieträger, aber ich entscheide mich für die Elektro-Lock.
Und du hast Recht behalten bis heute. Mich erinnert es tatsächlich an die Jugend. Ich war ja als Jugendlicher sehr oft auf Halfpipes unterwegs. Also ich kenne... Manche von euch wissen ja, was ich kann auf dem Brett, der es die Welt bedeutet. Und deswegen fühle ich mich hier eigentlich recht wohl, vor allem dann so cool und lässig hier lehnen. so. Das ist eigentlich auch immer so. Das ist cool. Moment, das erste Mal auf der Halfpipe,
so hey, na, das glaube, no. Ich meine so, hey, kann ich dir helfen oder so, aber du wolltest dich noch anmachen. Das coolste ist, wenn man da hochlaufen kann und dann so sitzen kann, ich probiere es mal, Achtung, haben wir in Arzt, Ärztin im Raum, auf Knöchel spezialisiert, irgendwie sowas vielleicht? Aber Frage, kurze Frage, weil man kann ja mit Motorrädern kann man ja in so einer Kugel Looping drehen. Genau. Und hier ist unser Motorrad. Könntest du jetzt theoretisch ein Looping laufen, wenn du nur schnell genug wärst? Ja, du meinst, kann ich ein Looping machen? Ja. Das ist deine Aufgabe, ich soll ein Looping machen? Nö, das war eher als Frage formuliert.
Ich zeige dir erstmal, wie man sich cool auf eine Half-Pap hinsetzt.
Okay, Achtung. Man muss erst mit viel Selbstbewusstsein anlaufen und dann...
Oh, fast! Ja, fast!
Wir dürfen nicht runterlaufen, das wurde uns verboten.
Hier haben sich schon ganz viele Leute alle Knochen gebrochen. Weiss jemand, was der schlimmste Unfall war, der hier jemals passiert ist? Schlüsselbeinbruch? Schlüsselbeinbruch? Oh wow, tatsächlich eine Art Ziel. Hat sich ein Hauptdarsteller ein Schlüsselbein gebrochen? Hast du mal gelesen, okay. Wow, das Gleisbein, nicht schlecht. Man kann natürlich auch hier viel in die Zuschauerrein fahren. Ich war nämlich mal dabei und ich weiß, wie rasant hier vorbeigefahren wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich diese bahnbrechende Geschwindigkeit für euch mal imitieren kann, aber das ist wirklich hier am Rande. Also da wird einem richtig schwindelig. Ich simulier's mal. Simulier's mal. Wow, das ist gefährlich. Das ist gefährlich. Ey, komm. Vor allem musst du dabei jetzt singen. Du musst dabei jetzt singen, dass du Rusty die Lok bist. Es wäre eine ganz andere Show. Starlight Express. Starlight Express. Und dann immer die Arme hoch bei den Seitenstechen. Sorry, ich kann nicht mehr. Mit der Magie der Zügel. Vor allem, wir waren ja hier, ne? Wir haben ja danach auch ein paar Storyfragen gehabt. Weil, man muss ja sagen, ich finde es cool, dass wir bewegte Scheinwerfer haben. Man fühlt sich wie bei GTA, wenn man drei Sterne hatte und der Helikopter auf dem Kaffee hat. Ja genau, der Hubschrauber, ja. Jetzt ist die Krieger ein immer, das ist schwierig. Aber wenn wir uns kurz kreuzen, dann bleiben die vielleicht, vielleicht wechseln sie sich dann ab. Nimmt der eine den anderen. Okay. Okay. Wow, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. So, das gibt es jetzt für 90 Minuten. Ihr werdet es einfach durch die Gegend. Ne, aber ich finde es, also, was ich problematisch finde an der Story, was ich schwierig fand zu verstanden, weil man muss sich ja den Star-Express als eine Art Macht vorstellen, so eine Star-Wars-artige The Force. Ja. Hast du es auch so verstanden? Ich dachte, es ist ein Zug. Ja, das ist halt das Problem, also es gibt halt alle, also Rusty betet wie zum Starlight Express, wie so eine Gottheit-Entität und betet dann zu ihm und dann ist aber ein anderer Zug und irgendwann sagt ihm, sinkt er zu dem Zug, der Zug antwortet ihm und sagt, nee, ich bin du. Problem, der Zug antwortet ihm. Nicht wieder dieses Ich bin du, ich warte, wenn du die Verspätung bist. Ich kann das nicht mehr, Stefan, diese Metaphern, ich komme da nicht mehr raus. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Es klappt nicht. Ja, und dann, wie hast du im Publikum gesessen? Das war dein Blick ungefähr die ganze Zeit. Ja, ich, what? Ich habe es auch nicht ganz verstanden, was genau das, aber vielleicht ist das die Magie des Starlight Express, dass man ihn nicht erklären kann und man ihn vielleicht in einem Achtklass-Schulaufgabelösung wiederfinden kann. Nein, manche Dinge entgehen den Achtklässlern. Und das ist die wahre Kunst. Das wollte Andrew Lloyd Webber uns sagen. Und das ist der Starlight Express. Ja, das ist der Starlight Express. Sehr gut. Das ist unglaublich, Wahnsinn. Es ist absurd. Es fühlt sich auch falsch an, hier was anderes als Starlight Express zu machen. Weil dieses Gebäude wurde tatsächlich nur für diese eine Show gebaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, wenn man so in der Kirche Tischtennis spielt oder so. Und man denkt sich, es fühlt sich falsch an. Ich meine, ich gewinne, aber es fühlt sich falsch an. Hast du das Gefühl, wir gewinnen? Aber ja, ich sehe das schon auch so. Vor allem, es ist ja in jedem anderen Land, in dem es lief, und es lief ja als Broadway-Musical wirklich in sehr vielen Ländern, läuft es inzwischen nicht mehr. Und ich frage mich, was brauchen die gerade in den Theatern, die dafür gebaut wurden, wo es aber nicht mehr läuft? Ich weiß es nicht. Und einfach so ein Einkaufszentrum, einfach so ein Hochgeschwierigkeit-Einkaufszentrum. Oder wie ein Skatepark, das wäre der beste Skatepark. Das ist wirklich der einzige Ort auf der ganzen Welt, wo Andrew Lloyd Webbers Traum noch am Leben ist. Es ist wirklich so, von allen gebauten Häusern dieser Art lebt nur noch das eine. Es ist noch kein Weltwunder, bald ist es soweit, aber es ist wirklich, hier kann man die Vision eines einzelnen Menschen sehen. Das achte Weltwunder, Andrew Lloyd Webber hat es gebaut. Ein harmloses Musical oder eine todbringende Verbindung zu den Aliens. Oder eine todbringende Schlüsselbeinbruchmaschine. Ja, aber es ist wirklich eine Ehre, hier zu sein. Und es ist aber auch weird, dass es das noch gibt, muss man auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen. So sehr ich mich freue, dass wir hier sein dürfen. Aber es ist schon merkwürdig, dass die deutschen Züge so toll finden, dass sie singenden Zügen in Kostümen, die sich, ich mache mir das nicht besonders viel Mühe geben, wie Züge auszusehen, weil sie sich nur Schulterpolster aufsetzen, zugucken beim Singen und bei einer Story. Und nicht ein einziges Mal Choo-Choo machen in der gesamten Show. Oh, es wird viel Choo-Choo-t. Es gibt Choo-Choo's? Es wird Choo-Choo-t. Echt? Früher noch mehr,
in der neuen Fassung weniger. Vor allem, es gibt ja
schon Thomas the Tank Engine.
Es gibt ja schon Zug-Franchise.
Zug-Franchise sind alle abgegrast.
Dann muss man erst Flugzeuge machen oder so,
Planes, das Musical. Aber Android Webber hat gesagt,
nein, das wäre aber ein Crossover, oder?
Thomas the Tank Engine meets
Starlight Express, einfach so als neuer
Charakter. Das fände ich nicht schlecht.
Okay, wie könnte so ein Song
aussehen? Naja, also ich bin ein Zug mit Dampf. Geil. Ja, ich kann auf den Gleisen fahren. Mega geil. Das heißt, du kannst keine Entscheidung treffen? Genau, ich kann keine Entscheidung treffen. Nein, ich fahre immer genau dahin, wo der Weg mich hin breitet, aber das ist ja ein schönes Metapher für das Schicksal und natürlich ... Dass man seinem Schicksal nicht entfliegen kann? Korrekt, ja. Aber ich kann auch singen. Okay, aber Ihre Botschaft ist, dass man seinem Schicksal nicht entgehen kann? Genau, dass es egal ist, welche Entscheidung man trifft, weil der Weg ohnehin gebaut ist. Aber es ist nicht so geil für Kinder, dass sie dann gesagt bekommen, ihr könnt eh nichts verändern. Ich glaube, es klingt besser als Song. Ne, wir haben Zeit. Also bitte, schließen Sie doch mal Ihn, du hast auch so ein Ghetto-Blaster zum Pitch-Meeting mitgebracht. Okay. Dann stellst du sie so hin. Ne, Track zwei, bitte. Track zwei, sorry. Du schaffst das.
Sicher, dass es Track zwei ist?
Ja, ja, okay.
Nee, nee, es ist so eine Reggae-Variante.
Warum?
Ich bin Thomas der Zug.
Ich bin richtig klug.
Ich kenne die Zukunft, denn sie steht auf den Gleisen, egal in welche Richtung.
Man kommt immer am Bahnhof an. Dankeschön, vielen Dank, danke schön. Stark, vielen, vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Aber warum nicht, es kommt vielleicht, es kommt zu. Aber wer von euch würde jetzt zum Beispiel, also wer von euch, der oder die ist noch nicht gesehen in das Musical, würde jetzt nach dem, es interessiert mich so doll, was eure Eindrücke sind von dem Theater. Vor allem, wer war von euch noch nicht hier? Okay, du. Was ist deine erste Frage? Warum gewinnt die Dampflok? Das ist ganz leicht zu erklären. Das ist ganz leicht zu erklären, das macht das Stück auch sehr klar. Dampf ist natürlich wichtig, weil Wasser ist in verschiedenen Aggregatszuständen vorhanden. Das wissen wir alle, Eis, Wasser und Wasserdampf. Genau, Wasser ist cool, alle lieben Wasser. Und die Kohle kann man verstehen als sozusagen so Antrieb, aber auch hier hier wird auch gesagt, dass... Du musst was verbrennen, um voranzukommen. Du musst auch was abwerfen können, um im Leben voranzukommen. Man muss Opfer bringen, um voranzukommen. Und wir haben nicht verstanden, wie Strom funktioniert. Also was ist das? Elektronen wackeln und dann... Also das ist halt schwer in den Song zu bringen. Er hat noch jemand anders eine Frage. Was ist in den Kabeln drin? Also niemand versteht es. Der Finalsong ist nämlich Diesel nimmt dir deinen Glauben, was auch immer das heißt. Das kann man nach jeder Zeile diesen Song sagen. Elektrizität schaffts nie. Dampferlein ist die Kraft, die uns jetzt vorwärts zieht. Es gibt ein Licht ganz am Ende des Tunnels, ist der Finalsong. Wir gehen nochmal durch. Tristina Stürmer haben wir durchgearbeitet. Wir widmen uns jetzt. Jetzt gehen wir in die neunte Klasse. Jetzt gehen wir in die neunte Klasse. Der Körper meldet sich langsam, Unterricht ist nicht mehr so interessant und jetzt kommt der Lehrer mit Starlight-X-Präs. Diesel nimmt dir deinen Glauben. Ja, das ist natürlich ganz klar, weil bei Diesel müssen Dinge verbrannt werden und das ist nicht gut. Das war doch gerade noch gut. Ja, Diesel. Wer versteht Diesel, wie funktioniert Diesel? Das sind irgendwelche Dinosaurier, die früher mal gestorben sind. Das ist gemein. Vielleicht brauchen wir das für später noch. Uncule Dinosaurier, die zu... Ja, zu uncoolem Treibstoff geworden sind. Elektrizität schafft es nie. Elektrizität schafft es nie. Sehen Sie, was kann Elektrizität eigentlich schaffen? Kann man mit Elektrizität zum Mond? Nein. Kann man mit Elektrizität Raum beleuchten? Manche, vielleicht, ja. Strom, niemand versteht Strom. Was ist Strom? Das kann man einfach nicht klar machen. Dampf allein ist das, was hier jetzt vorbeizieht. Dieses gesamte Gebäude wird komplett mit Dampf betrieben. Jede Lampe, die ihr seht, ist mit Dampf betrieben. Alles, was hier passiert. Es war ein bisschen ernüchternd, hinten die ganzen Leute zu sehen, die so schumpen im Kohleofen stehen. Es gibt Dampf, aber es gibt noch eine weitere fortschrittlichere Antriebstechnologie, nämlich die Energie, die von unseren reichen Menschen erzeugt wird, wenn sie sich dreht. Je mehr ihr euch dreht, je mehr wir hier durchlaufen, das ist das Kraftwerk der Zukunft. Wir laufen hier rum, ihr dreht euch und so entsteht Strom. Ah, ihr müsst ja schnell genug sein. Ich stelle mich jetzt hierhin. Ich stelle mich hinter die armen Leute, die sich hier hingesetzt haben, die eigentlich dachten, ja, wir haben schon coole Plätze. Kann man nichts gegen den Platz sagen. Aber da wusstet ihr nicht, dass ihr euch entscheiden müsst, das sind Stefan und mir. Ja gut, die meisten sind auf meiner Seite. I love you. Weiß ich so müssen. Gut, dass manche von euch sich ein Gesicht auf dem Hinterkopf gemalt haben, das ist eine gute, clevere Idee. Habt ihr euch schon mal direkt vorbereitet. Aber ist es so ein bisschen gimmicky wie so ein 4D-Kino oder macht es schon auch Spaß? Dass man so Dampf ins Gesicht kriegt? Macht schon Spaß, viele Daumen nach oben. Dass man sich dreht? Es ist abgefahren. Ich würde mir das überall wünschen, drehen der Stuhl alleine ist für mich 80 Prozent der Unterhaltung. Ich weiss, bei mir in der Schule früher war es so, wir hatten so komplett neue Klassenzimmer bekommen, als ich in die elfte Klasse gekommen bin, und dieses Klassenzimmer war komplett neu aufgebaut im Container, und es gab 30 Stühle. Im Container? Im Container, weil die haben gesagt, wo kommen diese ganzen Schüler her, wo sollen die alle lernen und dann haben sie einen Container aufgestellt.
Es war nicht vorherzusehen, wie viele Leute aus der siebten Klasse in die Achte kommen. Die dachten, mehr von uns fallen durch, die haben gesagt, nee, da fällt 80 Prozent durch, Infinitisimalrechnung, hallo, check kein Mensch, die fliegen alle raus. Zack, Container. Zack, Container, 30 normale Stühle, ein Stuhl mit Rollen unten dran. Das war wirklich so Hunger Games Lite, dass man gesagt hat, ja, und jetzt viel Spaß mit euch. Es war nicht der Stuhl des Lehrers, sondern es gab einen Stuhl bei den Schülern, der unten Rollen dran hatte. Und ich bin tatsächlich jeden Morgen zehn Minuten früher zur Schule gekommen, weil ich hatte ansonsten nicht viel zu bieten, ich war nicht der Beliebteste, aber ich hatte immer den Stuhl mit den Rollen. Ich hatte immer den Stuhl mit den Rollen. Also gab es so eine Dynamik, dass der Mensch mit dem Rollstuhl auch der beliebteste Mensch der Klasse war? Absolut. Das heißt, es hat sozial was für dich getan. Das soziale Gefüge hat sich in deine Richtung entwickelt. Normalerweise war es richtig unangenehm, wenn jemand hinter einem in der Bank einen ansprechen wollte und man musste so diesen, so wie ihr Trottel da, musste den machen, wohingegen ich, wenn du hinter mir mich ansprichst? Herr Florentin, kannst du mir kurz mit der Hausaufgabe helfen? Klar, gerne. Ach so, zack, und ich konnte mich sofort umdrehen. Ich dachte, du machst diesen Bösewicht. Ich weiß nicht, kann ich das? Und vor allem, du konntest den klassischen Arzt-Move machen, dich so mit einem Eimer abdrücken, so einfach zur Tafel katapultieren. Einfach so, deswegen kann das mal jemand zeigen an der Tafel, vielleicht Florentin. Und einfach wie so ein Curling-Spieler einfach zack, genau richtig landen. Und was ist das mit dir passiert, als ihr den Klassenraum gewechselt habt? Ich habe alle meine Macht verloren. Ich dachte, meine Herrschaft würde für ewig gelten, aber an dem Tag war sie komplett hinfort. Und ich saß neben der Heizung, was auch gut war. Gut war? Ich hatte den perfekten Platz damals. Ich glaube, ich war nie wieder so glücklich wie damals, als ich auf meinem Rollenstuhl mit Rollen an der Heizung saß. Und wenn sie so heiß wurde? Ja, bestimmt. Konnte ich einfach wegrollen. Ich hatte immer Gummibärchen dabei und habe die auf die Heizung gestellt und habe den Fernunterricht zugeschaut, wie sie schmelzen. Falls ihr euch fragt, warum ich heute grundlegende Dinge nicht verstehe und nicht weiß, weil ich lieber Forschung betrieben habe am Gummibärchen. Ich schaue da an den einen Hörer, die eine Hörerin von uns, die uns vorher gefragt hat, ob man Haribos hier mit reinnehmen kann. Ja, die einerseits hier Süßigkeiten reinschmuggeln wollte, aber trotzdem noch mal nachfragen wollte, ob man das auch kann. Ich glaube, nichts beschreibt ein Podcast-Lufo-Fan so gut wie, man will super ihren Haribo mitnehmen, aber man traut sich nicht aufzufliegen, man hat Angst vor der sozialen Interaktion, dieses, was haben Sie denn dabei? Sie haben offensichtlich eine Haribo-förmige Ausbeulung in der Hosentasche, zeigen Sie mal, was Sie in den Taschen haben, zeigen Sie mal, so sind die Leute hier beim Ein meinlass jetzt zeigen sie endlich mal und dann holst du es so raus ist das colorado schrecklich nein es sind ihr kids nicht es ist schwierig sie wollen kriminell sein wollen dafür aber die erlaubnis noch haben aber ich hoffe sie schmecken teilt gerne mal teilt ja baller baller was kein Wort verstanden aber nicht verstanden aber tobener Beifahr. Akustik in diesem Raum ist einfach nicht gut. Aber gerne teilen. Ich habe gemerkt, dass in letzter Zeit auf diesen Süßigkeitenpackungen immer mehr draufsteht, zum Teil. Was ist denn das eigentlich für eine Wahnsinnsidee? Wer schreibt das denn drauf? Das ist einzig und allein draufgeschrieben, um Leute sich schlecht fühlen zu lassen. Weil natürlich teile ich das nicht. So und vor allem, wer sieht denn, Entschuldigung, ich habe gerade gesehen, Sie sind gerade eingestiegen in den Zug, Sie essen da eine Parkung Colorado, da steht ja drauf zum Teilen. Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Ach so, hat Sie gesehen, das ist der Ruheabteil. Also ich schließe nicht, warum Sie nicht. Entschuldigung. Mein Name ist Florentin Will und ich bestehe darauf, Ich sie ihre Fresse hat. Ich glaube, vor allem in diesem Gebäude sollten wir mehr Respekt vor dem Ruheabteil haben. Gut, also, weil es gibt ja die Waggons. Früher waren die Frauen die Waggons und es gab einen Song, dass sie einen Mann brauchten, der sie wegbringt oder ans Ziel bringt. Problematisch wurde geändert. In? Waggons, die Frauen sind immer noch Waggons und kommen nicht ans Ziel ohne Mann, aber sie singen jetzt einen Song, dass sie mit sich zufrieden sind und mehr nicht brauchen. Was streng, wenn man der Story folgt und den ganzen Männern die Rennen für sie fahren, nicht stimmt. Sie kommen immer noch nicht ans Ziel, aber die Frauen, aber hast du einen geilen Ohrwurm. Vielleicht brauchen wir noch eine dritte Version von Side Express und ich würde vorschlagen Ruheabteil. Wir haben Silenthio. Silenthio, der ist Ruheabteil und dann so grosse krachende Musik und er trittst auf mit und alle, was? Ich habe Silenthio, ich habe die Storyline nicht verstanden. Ich habe die Storyline akustisch nicht verstanden. Ich sitze allein in meinem Wagen, es ist so leis, ich kann nicht klagen, was könnte schief gehen in dieser Welt? Ruhe, für Ruhe brauche ich kein Geld. Oh, Entschuldigung, okay, sorry. Das war der Song. Es ist schön, einfach mal Ruhe haben. Ich würde die Figur des Schlafwagens auch noch einführen. Der hat so eine Mütze auf und ist die ganze Zeit ein bisschen sleepy. Und er kommt nur am Ende und sagt, er hat die Show verschlafen. Oh Leute, könnt ihr ein bisschen leise sein? Ich versuche hier auch zu schlafen. Und das Ruheabteil sagt, ja, könnt ihr ein bisschen leise sein? Ja, und am Ende, genau, das Musical endet mit einem tschechischen Pass seht, ihr wisst warum, ich würde den ganzen Tag in dem Ruheabteil durch die Gegend fahren und einfach ... Oh, Herr mit Brille, vier Dezibel, so laut. Nie im Leben kriegst du an, Herr mit Brille. Oder ist es wie so ein Wer-ist-das-Spiel?
Es ist fantastisch.
Hat er eine Brille? Ja.
Es ist so Gamification. Hat er eine Brille?
Nee, aber das heißt, du kannst dann wahrscheinlich Sitznummern anschwerten.
Ich glaube ja. Vielleicht kannst du einfach die Leute zeigen. Aber es ist fantastisch.
Du kannst es auf Leute zeigen? Wie meinst du das?
Nee, ich glaube, da kommen dann auch so, ihr so, ich bin der mit dem roten Schal und dann kommt so der Schaffner vorbei bei dir so.
Wer ist es?
Gucken Sie jetzt nicht hin, aber es ist der Mann mit der Brille.
Es ist der Mann mit dem Podcast-Ufo-Shirt und der Brille.
Der seine Haribo nicht teilt?
Ja, genau der.
Ich kümmer mich drum.
Einfach in die Fresse.
Einfach direkt so.
Das ist ein anderes Land, andere Sitten.
Einfach so direkt.
Rein einfach.
Das wäre so ein Traum für mich.
Das wäre so schön.
Aber wir haben viele Zuschriften bekommen.
Also wo liegt die Petition inzwischen?
Ruheabteilpetition liegt, glaube ich, inzwischen bei über 20.000 Unterschriften.
Ja, da geht noch mehr.
Genau, aber du kannst jetzt ja locker schon den Bundestag so eine Bürgerbewegung einreichen.
Ja, aber das ist halt so viel Arbeit.
Da stehst du dann rum im Bundestag und sagst dir, dann haben die alle so coole Petitionen. Du willst nur keine Rede schreiben. Nee, nee, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, der nächste Schritt muss aus dem Volk herauskommen, wie gesagt. Ich glaube, dass wir wirklich so eine Art Aufstand brauchen, die einfach in den Zügen selbst einfach mal Rambazamba macht. Ich glaube, es muss eine Bewegung von unten sein. Eine ganze Bewegung von unten, die einfach, wir haben ein Zeichen, die Finger vor den Lippen, so erkennen wir uns auf der ganzen Welt und da werden wir alles revolutionieren. Du erkennst niemanden, wenn jemand so macht. Ich glaube, wir müssen nur irgendeine Legende in die Welt setzen, sodass die Aliens zuhören und wenn wir zu laut sind, dann vernichten die uns oder so. Und man hat so eine gewisse Anzahl Dezibel, die man so pro Woche verwenden kann und man muss sich gut überlegen, wo man leise ist und wo man laut ist und man hat nur ein gewisses Pensum und das darf man nicht überschreiten. Das wäre eine gute Idee, dass man einfach sagt, die Welt muss leiser werden. Und der nächste Sprecher ist Karl Lauterbach von der SPD. Das ist deine Rede im Bundestag? Wir müssen uns überlegen, Aliens und Lautstärke ist unsere Währung. Ja, ich wünsche dir viel Erfolg bei der, also ich glaube ja an dich. Ich glaube auch, du hast eine grosse Mehrheit, die da hintersteht und so. Ich glaube, das ist die richtige Halle, das richtige Theater, um das nochmal vorzubringen. Ich glaube, es muss ein Generationenumbruch sein. Ich glaube, die nächste Generation muss erzogen werden mit, wer laut ist, fliegt raus in Abteilen so. Und ich werde auch meine Kinder so erziehen, falls ich mal welche finde am Wegesrand oder so. Einfach, falls jemand zu viele Kinder hat oder so so, dann sage ich die, nee, ich stelle mir das wirklich vor, ich stelle mir das wirklich vor, wenn ich im Zug bin, jemand ist laut, ich stelle mir wirklich vor, wie ich meinem Kind sage, pass auf, wir fahren jetzt mit dem Zug, wir fahren jetzt mit dem riesigen Stahlwurm mit Hochgeschwindigkeit durch die Welt, das ist unfassbar, aber, als Koffer, warum schreist du mich so an? Du musst zu leise sein, wenn du nicht leise bist, dann drehen wir um und fahren wieder zurück. Das leise Spiel, wer zuerst was sagt hat, verloren. Fliegt halt raus. Gut, sehr gut. Hat jemand zu viele Kinder? Das ist halt das Problem mit Drillingen und so. Ich glaube, wenn man dann damit nicht rechnet, wenn man dann sagt, Entschuldigung, Sie haben Drillinge und jeder Ihrer Drillinge hat nochmal einen Zwilling.
Also Sie haben sechs Kinder, Sie haben nicht sechs Länge, Sie haben Drillinge, aber jeder der Drillinge hat nochmal einen Zwilling. Das heißt, Sie haben drei Zwillinge und drei Drillinge. Also würdest du mir sagen, dass Drillinge eigentlich Zwillinge sind mit einem Attachment? Nee, nee, das sind schon drei Drillinge. Aber jeder von denen hat noch mal einen Zwilling. Verstehen Sie? Ich stelle mir so einen harten Cut vor, wie ihr alle nach Hause fahrt in Autos. Und drüber nachdenkt. Aber sorry, ich glaube auch jeder Arzt hatte mal den Gedanken, einfach zu pranken und einfach bei so einem Ultraschall zu sagen, ja sind noch fünf. Noch fünf geworden. Fünf geworden. Fünf. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, herzlichen Glückwunsch, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Es sind vier Vierlinge und einer extra. Der hat mit den anderen, der hat gar nichts mit den anderen zu tun. Der ist ein Stück grösser, dick, blonde Haare und die anderen... Kommt mehr nach ihrem Mann. Die anderen vier sind exakt gleich blonde Haare. Der eine ist zusätzlich. Warum nicht? Bitte werdet kein Arzt. Ja, jetzt wo du sagst, ich war schon kurz vor dem Abschlussexamen, aber jetzt werde ich es lassen. Ich hatte schon fast alle Knochen, außer den Ringzeh. Da weiß ich immer nicht, wie er heißt. Daumenseh, Zeigezeh, Ringzeh. Gibt es da coole Namen für die Zehen eigentlich? Wir fragen die reichen Leute. Habt ihr schon mal, dass euch Zehen transplantieren lassen? Nee, ich glaube tatsächlich nicht. Ich glaube, vor allem Zehen habe ich gehört, brechen im Laufe deines Lebens sieben Mal. Jeder? Kann man sich merken, weil man isst auch im Schlaf sieben Spinnen in seinem Leben. Und man versucht, die Spinnen wegzutreten und dann bricht man sich den Zeh direkt an der Wand etwa jedes Mal. Man bricht sich den Zeh siebenmal im Leben im Schnitt, manche deutlich mehr. Aber denselben Zeh siebenmal oder sieben Zehen werden gebrochen. Sieben Zehen je einmal. Genau. So ein Akkord, so ein grosser so auf alle Zehen drauf. Aber man merkt es nicht, es tut einfach weh,
es fühlt sich an wie verstaucht,
weil es auch keiner genau weiss, was es ist.
Du darfst sowas nicht sagen, seit ich mein Zeh gebrochen habe,
fühle ich immer so in meine Zehen rein. Aber ich glaube, du bist der Erste, der dann damit zum Arzt gegangen ist.
Ja, die wussten ja auch nicht, was zu tun war.
Aber so Zeh...
Bist du zum Arzt gegangen, war der dann wirklich, der war auf 90 Grad?
Der stand 90 Grad vom Rest des Fußes ab. Okay. Da war selbst mir als medizinischem Laien klar, dass hier was passieren muss, dass ich hier nicht mehr weiterkomme. Hast du trotzdem gegoogelt, ob du zum Arzt musst? Symptome abstehender Zehen. Und er dachte, fuck, ich habe auch noch Krebs, war das denn das denn? Scheiss, Krebs. Zehenkrebs. Aber es ist schwierig. Und das ist tatsächlich so, weil du, bevor du dir einen Knochen gebrochen hast, hast du kein Gefühl für deinen Körper, dass er kaputt gehen könnte. Du denkst, du bist unverwundet. Ach so, ich dachte gerade, du merkst, dass gleich was Schlimmes passiert. Das auch. So eine Vorahnung. Und deswegen, sie ist dann so, ja, wir drücken den jetzt wieder zusammen so und dann gucken wir, was passiert. Aber der kann aber sein, dass der wieder bricht. Und seitdem stehe ich jeden Morgen auf mit fühlt er sich gebrochen an, geht da noch was, ist da noch was und man hat ja kaum Kontakt zu seinen Zehen, man ruft ja da selten an. Das ist der weitest entfernte weitest entfernt. Die Zehen fragen sich so, wer will das wissen? Stefan? Nee, Flogentin will. Der war noch mal ganz kurz, wer noch mal? Ich bin nur ein Nervenbündel, was von deinem Hirn hier runtergeschickt wurde. Ich war hier noch nie hier unten. Der muss sich vernervt haben. Ihr müsst hier dringend sauber machen. Hier bei uns unten kommt nie was. Ich muss ihm sagen, dass er beim Duschen auch mal unten die Füße ein bisschen sauber machen. Ja, das kannst du sagen. Wir haben einmal die Katjes Werbung gedreht, aber danach haben wir zehn nie wieder irgendwas gemacht. Das war unser einziger glänzender Moment. Danach gar nichts mehr. Mir sind die alle zu leger. Die sind viel zu gemütlich. Zu gemütlich. Die fallen so zurück. Aber ihr könnt euch richtig schnell drehen. Also wirklich, ihr habt keine Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung. Ihr könnt euch richtig wahnsinnig schnell drehen. Aber ich glaube, es ist psychologisch, weil in diesen New Yorker Comedy Clubs, in denen wir waren, super unbequeme Stühle, alle sitzen kerzengerade und erfreuen sich an dem wenigen, was sie bekommen und freuen sich. Hier, die Haltung, die ihr habt, ist eine ganz andere. Die Haltung, die die reichen Leute hier haben, hier vorne, die mehr bezahlt haben für die Tickets, die ist direkt so, ja, also wir haben hier dafür bezahlt. Ich weiß nicht, was das jetzt hier, wenn es Laber ist. Jeder kann euch sehen und glaubt nicht, dass ihr am Parkplatz nicht direkt überfallen werdet, einfach so. Wir haben hier viele Leute, die nur von Haribo leben und euch ganz genau die Gesichter merken und dann schön auf dem Weg nach Hause. Na hier, du bist so einer von den Drehern, dreht sich schön bei dir zu Hause. Du hast doch gerade da unten gedreht. Jetzt drehen wir nicht mal. Einfach so die Gangs, die Dreher und die Geraden. Die Dreher und die Steher. Die Dreher gegen die Steher ist auch nicht schlecht. Haben wir Stehplätze? Wir hatten einmal Stehplätze. Das war das Unangenehmste. Da hatten wir einen Auftritt in Wien, das war eine Live-Show von vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren. Und da hat uns dann jemand, der mit uns dann da war, und dann wechselte die Zeit gesagt, wir haben zu viele Karten verkauft, jetzt haben wir Stehplätze. Steher, na wir haben die Steher. Bei uns Steher hatten wir. Steher. Und das war das unangenehmste der Welt für uns jemals. Es war uns sehr leid, aber am Ende hatten die vielleicht einen schönen Abend, weiß ich. Du kannst dich auch drehen. Wenn du stehst, kannst du dich viel leichter drehen. Du kannst dich wahnsinnig schnell drehen. Die hatten damals schon 360-Grad-Plätze. Es ist ein Vorteil. Man sollte sich auch häufiger drehen im Leben. Ich weiß, als Kind habe ich ständig gemacht. Nichts Gutes im Fernsehen, drehen. Irgendwie Mutter nicht da, drehen. Das war meine Antwort so. Und ich habe nicht mal einen Stuhl dafür gebraucht, ich habe einfach gedreht.
Und dann war mir so schwierig, dass ich gegen die Wand gelaufen bin.
Das war ein guter Nachmittag.
Ach so, du hast wirklich literally gedreht, du hast dich nicht woanders hingeredet.
Wie Hunde das manchmal machen, wenn man Fernsehen guckt und sie entscheiden sich einfach nicht,
dass das das Spannende ist, was gerade im Fernsehen passiert,
sondern dann gucken sie einen selber an oder so.
Weil Hunde haben da kein Gefühl für und dann drehen sie sich einfach woanders.
Aber du hast dich literally einfach die ganze Zeit gedreht. Ja, ich meine, als Kind, dein Kind, du erlebst deinen Körper ja völlig neu. Du weißt, dass die Menschen die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen, die Menschen jeden Tag, seitdem nicht mehr gemacht. Und ich werde es hier auch nicht machen, aber sonst falle ich auf euch drauf. Und das wollt ihr nicht, dann falle ich in eure Grube da rein. Aber ist der Schlüsselbein gebrochen gewesen, weil ihr ein Darsteller hier umgekippt ist oder ist das Schlüsselbein eines Zuschauers gebrochen worden? Darsteller. Er liest nur Headlines. Du glaubst ja nicht ernsthaft, dass jemand hier in die Zuschauer fällt und genau deren Schlüsselbein tritt oder nicht? Mit den Rollen voran so in das Schlüsselbein rein. Aber dann muss aber zurückgedreht sein, also dass du dann direkt so von hinten rein... Ja, weil die sehen hier so leger aus, hat er sich auch gedacht. Hat sich Elektra die Dampflok, nein, die offensichtlich nicht Dampflok, ist hingefahren und hat ihm Schlüsselbein geballert. So, jetzt lauft er mal runter. Das einzige, was wir nicht machen dürfen, ist da runter zu laufen. Es ist so abgefahren. Ich meine, wer will uns abhalten? Die Leute, die hier arbeiten. Das stimmt. Da wird man von der Bühne gezerrt. Dann kommen so zehn Security-Leute auf Rollschuhen an hier einfach. Zack, zack, zack und täckeln nicht um. Das ist gefährlich. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich gefährlich. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich gefährlich. Aber wer, ist es nicht so, dass Dinge in Bewegung, die sind doch eher, sind die eher sicher oder eher nicht sicher? Also angenommen, ein Auto steht und ein anderes Auto fährt 80 kmh und die fahren frontal ineinander rein, wer überlebt? Oder überlebt dann niemand mehr? Weißt du, als wir das in der Schule beigebracht haben, habe ich einem armen Gummibärchen dabei zugeschaut, wie es langsam vergeht. Falls du es wissen willst, die gelben schmilzen am schnellsten. Gelben schmilzen am schnellsten. Die gelben schmilzen am schnellsten, die gelben schmilzen am schnellsten, die gelben schmilzen am schnellsten. Und die roten kommen nicht hinterher, es ist Gummibärchen das Musical. Gummibärchen das Musical. Ja, jetzt kommt ihr nicht mehr raus, die Türen sind schon verschlossen, ihr könnt nicht mehr gehen, jetzt müsst ihr uns liebe Gummibärchen ansehen. Auch nicht schlecht. Ich bin eine Zimtschnecke. Oh nein, es ist die Zimtschnecke. Hab keine Angst, wir sind sehr langsam. wir bringen den Plot nicht voran.
Oh nein, liebe Gummibärchen, wir müssen uns schnell retten auf diese warme Fläche dort hinten. Schnell, hier sind wir sicher.
Ich bin das rote Gummibärchen, ich bin viel beliebter als die anderen.
Hey, rotes Glühwimmchen, warum bist du immer so gemein zu uns?
Weil ich cooler bin. Erklär es in einem Song. Rote Gummibärchen sind doch die...
Hey, ich bin rot, ich werde immer sofort gegessen, weil ich die mit Abstand coolste Geschmackrichtung bin. Ich bin Kirsch oder Himbeer oder Himbeer oder beides oder beides. Ich bin rot, kommt auf das Jahr an, es kommt auf die Sonderedition an. Oh nein, meine Füsse, sie kleben fest, ich komme nicht vom Fleck, jetzt kommt der Reggae-Teil.
Warum immer Reggae, Alter? Weg vom Reggae.
Du bist wie so eine Motte, die auf Reggae zusteuert.
Das kommt aus den Neunziger.
Reggae?
Ich weiß es doch nicht, ich weiß es doch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das erste Mal Reggae gehört habe.
Darum geht es doch auch gar nicht. Es gibt drei Reggae-Songs.
Der Beat läuft noch.
Das ist der ganze Teil, Akt zwei, wie sich die Hauptfiguren ausserhalb der Rolle streiten. Und es ist immer noch verständlicher als Starlight Express. Das ist einfach so. Ja, das habe ich verstanden. Das ist kein Problem. Die Kuhmädchen schmelzen und sind alle tot und damit ist das Musical vorbei. Danke. Wir haben leider kein Gebäude bauen können, das dieses Musical perfekt umgesetzt hat, deswegen müssen wir uns hiermit befassen. Ich bin so gespannt, was hiermit passiert, wenn Starlight Express irgendwann nicht mehr... Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, toi, toi, toi. Starlight Express wird niemals untergehen. Ich topfe auf Linoleum, Karbonat, Polyethylen, aber was passiert hiermit, wenn das nicht mehr passiert? Salve Express kann sich immer weiterentwickeln. Wenn wir irgendwann so Saugröhren haben, dann wird es einfach umgeschrieben in so ein Saugröhrenmusical. Saugröhrenmusical? Hyperloop. Ja genau, Hyperloop. Und dann wirst du halt rumgesaugt und dann musst du halt diese Bahnen ersetzen durch Röhren und dann mit Anlauf durchlaufen, wie so eine Rutsche oder sowas. Man kann nichts erkennen. Man erkennt keine Darsteller mehr. Es ist zu rasant. Starlight Express wird es immer geben. Solange Menschen von A nach B wollen, wird es Starlight Express geben. Nicht wahr? Glaubt ihr an den Starlight Express? Seid ihr mit dabei? Aber hat irgendwer von euch jetzt Lust, das Musical zu sehen, allein um zu wissen, warum diese Schienen hier da sind? Ich dachte tatsächlich, als ich hier die Show gesehen habe, fahren die Leute hier durch und ich dachte wirklich, ich kann denen ein Bein stellen. Ich habe wirklich die ganze Zeit, und das denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich auch die ganze Zeit, ich könnte in die Seite einfach umhauen. Aber ich weiß nicht, was falsch mit mir ist, aber ich konnte nicht anders, als die ganze Zeit mir zu denken, ich könnte jetzt alles kaputt machen. Für alle. Ich könnte alles zerstören. Hast du das nicht immer, wenn du in Situationen, wo du ruhig sein musst, so zum Beispiel wie ihr jetzt oder wie wenn man in der Philharmonie ist oder sowas. Und dann habe ich immer so Angst, dass ich irgendwie aus einem Anflug von Wahnsinn laut was Doofes schre Ja. Habt ihr das nicht? Nein. Nein. Sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Dieses klassische Sag jetzt nichts Dummes, sag jetzt nicht Dummes. Beim Zahnarzt denke ich mir das auch so. Das ist der schlechteste Moment, um dummes Gespräch zu bewegen. Schluck jetzt nicht, denke ich mir da. Schluck jetzt nicht. Sie hat gesagt, nicht schlucken. Ja, aber nicht schlucken. Und du machst dir nie Gedanken über schlucken, aber in dem Moment ist es das beste der Welt. Es ist das schönste Gefühl der Welt, du willst es einfach tun. Man kriegt diesen Sauger, ich habe einmal selber diesen Sauger bekommen, um mir den Speichel raus, weil manchmal darf man nicht schlucken und dann kriegt man so einen Speichelsauger und das fand ich perfekt, weil ich weiss ja selber am besten, wo mein Speichel gerade Pfützen bildet in meinem Mund. Und dann habe ich das gemacht, habe auch den bei dem Mund zugemacht, weil ich vergessen habe, dass ich einen Sauger im Mund habe. Und dann ist mein, jeder kennt das, wenn man den Sauger irgendwo dran hält, gegen so eine Matratze oder sowas, alles wird reingesogen, dann habe ich so ein, dann war mein, hat es die ganze Zeit so gemacht. Alle haben sich mega erschrocken, es waren so vier Arzt,fer da. Und alle haben sich mega erschrocken. Und ich wurde so sorry. Das ist der worst outcome. Und du warst einmal so komplett auf links gedreht. Ich war auf links. So komplett aus nach innen. Komplett vakuumiert. Und dann so, keine Angst, hier haben wir das gebläsen, aber wieder so rein und dann bist du wieder zurückgerichtet.
Ja, wie so eine Matratze, so eine aufblasbare Matratze, die man aber auch, ich habe es gesehen, die Motoren haben, wo man das auch rauslassen kann, die Luft so weich, einfach so aufgegangen. Ich bin der Speichelsauger, ich sauge Speichel ein, halt dann den Mundraum, halt ich fröhlich rein, doch Copyright macht mir einen Strich durch die Rechnung. Ihr kommt ja schon mein Anwalt, er hat die Klage in der Hand und was will er mir sagen? Sie sind verhaftet, Sie müssen jetzt gehen, Sie müssen ins Gefängnis, Sie haben den Sauger in der Hand. Aber Herr Anwalt, die Menschen, was sollen Sie machen ohne Speichelsauger, wie sollen Sie sonst den Speichel aus Ihrem Mund rauskriegen? Sie kam Jahrzehnte ohne Speichelsauger klar und dann laufen sie weg. Und ich wusste, es ist wahr. Ende. Auch Musicals, und das ist, glaube ich, die Lektion von heute. Musicals können auch kurz sein. Man kann auch mal das in so TikTok-Länge einfach durchballern, und dann ist gut. Backstage war so ein altes Plakat vom Sala Express, wo irgendwie drauf stand, jetzt irgendwie neue Saison, noch schneller. Man stand noch schneller begeistert und ich dachte mir, noch schneller vorbei, wäre auch lustig für so Väter, die eigentlich keine Lust haben, mit hinzugehen. Aber es ist ein guter Plakat. Man muss sagen, die meisten Dinge sind zu lang, oder? Filme. Zu lang. Ich habe noch einen Film gesehen, 83 Minuten. Oh, herrlich. Wenn er schlecht ist, perfekt. Wenn er gut ist, ist er ja immer noch gut. Man kann es noch mal angucken. Man kann es noch mal angucken. Weil du es gerade sagst, mit beim Zahnarzt verschlucken, ist es mir tatsächlich passiert, ich hatte ja lange eine Zahnspange aus Gold, nicht weil es medizinisch nötig war, sondern einfach weil ich reich bin. Weil du reich bist. Alle hier unten auch, Zahnspange aus purem Gold. Die Dreher nicken, ja, okay, klar. Und da war es tatsächlich auch so, dass da war so ein Draht hinten an den Zähnen dran und mit Gold wurde der Draht befestigt. Und da war es wirklich oft so, dass die Zahnärzte-Kieferorthopädin das so rumgefummelt hat und dann ist manchmal eins dieser Goldstücke abgefallen auf meine Zunge. Und dann hat sie mir gesagt, jetzt auf keinen Fall schlucken. Und das ist dreimal passiert. Und es ist natürlich in genau dem Moment,
wenn jemand sagt, jetzt nicht schlucken.
Und der ganze Raum, wir hören mal rein.
Achtung, nicht schlucken auf eins, zwei, drei.
Okay.
Das haben wir nicht gehört,
aber gefühlt, wie der Raum plötzlich
kleiner wurde. Und ich habe tatsächlich
so ein Goldstück verschluckt.
Ich habe insgesamt, glaube ich, drei Goldstücke
verschluckt von diesen Dingern.
Und hast du da mit so einem Sieb?
Nee, da will ich nicht drüber reden, bitte.
Das ist einer der Tiefpunkte meines Lebens.
Hör auf. Goldgräber?
Nee, da will ich nicht drüber reden.
Da will ich wirklich drüber reden.
Da ist so ein Sieb gestanden.
Ich habe auch mal ein Hühnchen gegessen.
Und dann die Mutter so, Flo und die, was machst du denn da schon wieder im Klo so lange?
Masturbierst du?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe angefangen zu masturbieren, als sie reingekommen ist, weil ich nicht erklären konnte. Jesus. Es ist wirklich eines der Schlimmste. Ich habe auch mal Hähnchen gegessen und das war so fucking knusprig, Lob, dass es mir tatsächlich auch eines dieser Goldbrackets rausgegrissen hat. Kritik. Kritik, ja. Nee, Kontra. Und ich es mit dem Hühnchen, lecker, runtergeschluckt habe, toi. So, toi. Und dann war es verschluckt und dann rufe ich halt auch da an so, ja, guten Tag, Florentin hier. Ich habe mal wieder Gold verschluckt. Ja, dann müssen Sie suchen gehen. Und ichge auf und denke es sei nach über diesen satz und man das will ich gar nicht erzählen es ist so
doch ich will es hören ich will es hören nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
komm da oben nein wir haben ja lassen es nur für uns bleiben hier muss unter uns bleiben
ist es in die geheimnissecke kurz nicht mitbekommen. Okay, und dann habe ich kurz nachgedacht, was sie wohl gemeint hat mit Ich soll suchen. Was sie wohl gemeint hat mit Ich soll suchen. Und was hast du gesagt? Und dann wurde es mir plötzlich, ich hatte es schon aufgelegt, aber es wurde mir plötzlich dramatisch klar, Moment mal, diese Leuchten, die verraten uns, diese Schweine!
Ja, wer lag richtig? Seid ehrlich, seid ehrlich. Jetzt erklär, was hat sie gesagt, da müssen sie suchen. Och Mensch, Stefan, ey, wirklich, das ist, kannst du das jetzt nicht so, du hast es am Haken. Es war wirklich fucking furchtbar. Und das Schlimmste war, dass ich nichts gefunden habe.
Also, ich sage mal so, ich habe schon was gefunden,
aber nicht das, wonach ich gesucht habe.
So, jetzt ist es auch beendet jetzt.
Weil mir ist was Ähnliches passiert. Da machen wir jetzt kein witziges Musical oder so draus,
das Thema ist beendet.
Ich glaube, ich habe das sogar, das ist jetzt unangenehm,
ich glaube, ich habe das sogar schon mal erzählt
und dann aus dem Podcast rausgeschnitten,
weil es so fucking ekelhaft war.
Und jetzt kann ich, obwohl, es sei denn, das bleibt hier unter uns. Das geht jetzt nicht raus an die Außenwelt. Da filmt jemand, ich glaube, es bleibt nicht unter uns. Ich habe nämlich mal eine Murmel verschluckt. Was hast du verschluckt, ein Pulli? Eine Murmel. Ach, eine Murmel. Ich dachte, einen Pulli habe ich verschluckt. Mama, das war ja Sauger-Inzident. Ich wollte von innen warm sein. Ach, Gott. Du bist von innen warm. Nee, dann habe ich eine Murm verschluckt. Weird, weird story. Und dann hat der Arzt gesagt, nee, ist schon okay, das Essen geht daran vorbei. Die braucht halt lange, aber suchen sie danach, hat er auch gesagt. Das Essen geht daran vorbei. So die Hot Dogs so, Morgan, hi, alles klar.
Kennen Sie sich hier aus?
Nein, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich hier bin, ich bin im Murmel.
Wir sind gerade angekommen, wir wurden gerade gegessen, wir waren noch nicht hier.
Sie können einfach vorbei.
Alles klar, danke.
Ciao.
Oh, Körper, das Körperinnere, das Musical.
Oh, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Ich möchte nicht singen mehr, aber Körperinnere, das Theaterstück geht auch. Aber. Ich bin das rote Blutkörperchen, ich hab viel für euch vor, ich sorge dafür, dass viel gelingt in unserem Körpertor. Boah, Ich kann besser Sauerstoff transportieren als reimen.
Und bitte verschütt mich nicht, denn du hast nur neun Liter von mir,
mehr hast du leider nicht.
Drum-Solo!
Sind so Knochen.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Die Trommelfelle sind Haut die Trommel selbst sind Schädel ich habe hier mehr am Bühnenbild gearbeitet als am Text muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen wie glaube ich auch Andrew Lloyd Webber glaube ich sich mehr gesagt hat Herr Webber wie lautet der Text äh die Bar diese nimmt geht einmal um hier. Und dann kommt noch was von oben runter und so, ja, aber wer ist die Hauptfigur? Ach, Hauptfigur, Alpha, das fährt da runter. Drehende Sessel, ja, Sie haben den Job. Das war Andrew Lloyd Webbers Idee, dass ihr euch drehen könnt, nicht unsere Idee. Aber es ist schon geil, also stell dir mal vor, da ist ein Theater für jemanden gebaut, ich glaube Shakespeare und Andrew Lloyd Webber. Für die beiden wurde ein Theater genau nach deren Ideen und Vorstellungen gebaut. Aber er hat es quasi Shakespeare noch überholt, weil er es auch noch geschafft hat. Es gibt wie eine verlorene Wette. Ich schaff's mit singenden Zügen, dass sehr viele Menschen auf der ganzen Welt Theater bauen. Wie viel fucking Selbstbewusstsein muss ein Mensch sagen, haben, dass man sagt, nee, baut da mal drei. Mein Musical ist so gut, dass ihr drei Gebäude baut, wo nur dieses Musical gespielt wird. König der Löwen auch? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee, nee, Pinocchio? Nein. Das Körperinnere, das Musical? König der Löwen geht in ein Zelt. König der Lohnlöwen soll in ein scheiß Zelt in Hamburg. Und das hier ist einfach ein riesenmächtiges Theater, wo man rumfahren kann als Zug. Das ist fantastisch. Ich kann es jedem empfehlen. Auch wenn ihr die Story verstanden habt, schreibt uns danach eine Mail an Podcast. Ich meine, mittlerweile kennen wir uns gut aus mit Textinterpretationen. Wir haben viel beigebracht den Leuten, glaube ich, mittlerweile sollte man sich auskennen mit Textinterpretationen. Man weiss, wie es geht. Die Leute wissen, wie es geht. Es ist ja auch nicht so schwer. Nee, Sie können uns helfen. Es gibt noch einen sehr weirden Text, den möchte ich euch durchführen. Wie gesagt, wir haben Erfahrungen mit Christina Stürmer, es gibt einen weirden Text aus der alten Fassung. Genau, die alte Fassung Style Express, noch mysteriöser und rätselhafter als die aktuelle. So, vielleicht könnt ihr uns auch helfen. Haben wir Deutschlehrer hier? Nein, das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gedacht. Ich hätte mich auch nicht gemeldet. Aber es geht um Cabuz. Cabuz ist der Bremswagen. Er ist superlieb, wird dargestellt als auch ein Freund, er singt so einen Song über Liebe, whatever. Also die Figur ist ein Wagen. Ein Bremswagen. Was ist ein Bremswagen. Er ist super lieb, wird dargestellt, er ist auch ein Freund, er singt so einen Song über Liebe, whatever. Also die Figur ist ein Wagen? Ein Bremswagen. Was ist ein Bremswagen? Ich glaube, früher gab es Bremswagen, korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, die hinten am Zug dran befestigt waren und alte Züge gebremst haben, Dampfloks können nicht bremsen. Wie sollen Dampfloks denn bremsen? Okay. Wahrscheinlich gab es hinten dann so einen Wagen, wo man einfach, der der sich sich einfach wie hingesetzt hat. Aber interessante Figur, also wir haben eine Figur, die ein Wagen ist, die eigentlich nur zurückhält. Genau, und sie am Ende, Spoiler, kleiner Spoiler für Star Express, die wird dann irgendwann böse. Und der Reveal-Song, wo er auskommt, oh, ist eigentlich ein böser Charakter, er lässt lässt andere Züge entgleisen, ist mein Ziel, mein Spiel, glaube ich, heißt es, mein Spiel. Okay, ich fange an, den Text vorzutragen. Okay, zuhören, die Metaphern sind fein. Jeder hält, egal warum, endet schliesslich durch Betrug. Das ist die alte Übersetzung auch, ich finde, es holpert ein bisschen, willst du nicht? Held, egal warum, endet schliesslich durch Betrug. Achtung, Robin Hood behielt die Beute, Heidi ärgerte die Leute, wirklich? E.T. dürfte gar nicht fliegen, Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen, Bambi steckt den Wald in Brand und Cabuz macht nicht vor bösem Halt. Das ist der Text. Und als Kind fand ich die Musik toll. Man stellt sich das Publikum vor, dass das als erstes hört. Robin Hood behält die Beute? Also jeder Held, egal warum, ähne schließlich durch Betrug, Robin Hood behielt die Beute, Heidi ärgerte die Leute. Ist die Story von Heidi nicht, dass sie aufs Land kommt, wo niemand ist? War Heidi die Volleyball spielt, oder welche war Heidi noch nie? Bitte was? Nee, ich hab wirklich Heidi, sorry, ich bin hier ... Das ist so bedrohlich mit dem Licht, wenn man auf mich zukommt.
Irgendwo hat er die Erfolge zu dem Licht.
Was du gesagt hast.
Ist das ein Problem mit Heidi, oder was?
Was du gerade gesagt hast.
Nein, nein, bitte leuchten Sie mich nicht an, Herr Dietzer.
Aber was ist die Grundstory von Heidi?
Heidi flieht vor den Kommunisten, ich weiß nicht.
Was die Story ist, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ach nee, aber warum ist die auf dem Land?
Doch, doch, wir kriegen das zusammen hin.
Heidi war doch ungezogen, oder nicht, und sollte wegen der Landluft dann Leute nicken, die Reichen nicken. Heidi musste Landluft, sollte Landluft erzogen werden von dem alten Alben. Heidi ist wie Kaviar, das ist ab einem gewissen Einkommen kann man das machen. Dann stimmt die Metapher. Heidi hat Leute geärgert? Nein, nein, nein, nein, sie beschweren sich. So reagiert ihr im Musical, nein, hat sie nicht getan, Heidi war die Gute, sie wurde geärgert, wirft die Brezel einfach. Das ist ja unsere Hauptfigur, Heidi ärgerte die Leute, E.T. dürfte gar nicht fliegen, finde ich auch schwierig, weil es war nicht das Problem, also E.T. wurde nicht gesucht, weil er durch den Luftraum, den gesperrten Luftraum geflogen ist. Machen wir jetzt Filmfehler in einem Musical, Filmfehler, das Musical, ich bin dabei, ich habe Zeit, ja, kein Problem, ja, aber das ist schon merkwürdig zu sagen, E.T. sollte gar nicht, E.T. ist ein fucking Alien, das kann machen, was es will. Genau, die Anwesenheit eines Aliens hat die Leute irritiert, beziehungsweise dazu gebracht, ihn zu jagen. Nicht, weil er geflogen ist und gesagt hat, das geht nicht runter. Also E.T. dürfte gar nicht fliegen und jetzt Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen. Was? Ist es das coolste Crossover der Welt? Donald Duck ist eine Ente, Kermit ist ein Frosch. Zwei verschiedene Franchises.
Die haben nichts miteinander zu tun.
Das eine ist doch wie Marvel und DC.
Die kommen doch nicht zusammen.
Ja, stimmt. Es ist auch immer so, Donald wurde jetzt von DC unter Vertrag genommen.
Einfach so, das ist auch mal eine Nachricht.
Für 200 Millionen Euro Transfer.
Bambi steckt den Wald in Brand.
Hab ich anders in Erinnerung.
Ich auch.
Ich meine, sie hat geraucht im Film. Daran erinnere ich mich.
Bambi hat geraucht? Bambi hat doch geraucht und die Zigarette weggeschnitten, oder nicht?
Also Mutter, schade, dass du tot bist. Komm, lass uns das geheime Metall suchen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von dem Film. Aber Bambi steckt den Wald in Brand?
Ja, und wenn dir dann noch die originale Aufnahme anhört, wird es noch verwirrender,
weil der offensichtlich nicht deutschsprachige Sänger singt, Bambi steckt den Brand in Wald. Also er hat den Christina Stürmer gemacht, er hat den ohnehin so verwirrenden Song falsch gesungen. Und der Sound Engineer hat gesagt, das passt so, ja, das passt schon. Alle Zeilen davor führen jetzt nicht dazu, dass ich diese Zeilen in Frage stellen will. Wahrscheinlich steckt sie den Brand in Wald. So, und dann habe ich da vorgesessen, so ein kleines Radio damals, als ich so, keine Ahnung, elf Jahre alt war, habe diesen Song immer gehört. Und ich stelle mir immer meine Eltern vor, die gesagt haben, was hört der Mensch da? Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen. Was? Ich meine, das muss von jemandem geschrieben worden sein, der einfach nebenbei dieses Ding hier designte und einfach so, ja, Donald, irgendwas, Kermit hier, Scooby-Doo, Scheisse drauf. Wir brauchen die neuen Texte. Was braucht ihr? Für mein Spiel. So was wie Bummy steckt den Wald im Brand, Kermit will an Donald ran. Ciao. Mach's gut, sing das. Ich spreche doch kein Deutsch, mir doch egal, was Sie da singen. I don't speak German. Jetzt müssen wir natürlich unseren Christina Stürmer geschärften Verstand ansetzen. Was soll das heißen? Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen. Also, wir haben es ja hier mit sympathischen Sympathieträgern zu tun. Genau, die eigentlich was Gutes sind, E.T. Bambi, waren aber alle nur sozusagen, hatten auch eine dunkle Seite, Robin Hood behält den Schatz für sich. Aber Harvey Harvey Dent wäre ja ein besseres Beispiel gewesen. Der war ja immer gut und ist dann Two-Face. Ja, okay, gut. Ja, oder es gibt viele Figuren, die anfangs gut waren, später böse. Ja, genau, Heidi, mich. Oder irgendeiner von denen, ich weiß es nicht, genau, aber der war früher cool und dann so, nee, es fragte ich Jesus. Ja, Jesus Christ Superstar, auch von Andrew Lloyd Webber, also eben schließlich der Kreis. Hätte man da greifen. Aber es ist schon merkwürdig, weil Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen. Also er muss, das ist was Schlechtes, dass Donald Duck Kermit kriegen will, aber was... Aber war nicht der Versuch, also bei Caboose singt, Menschen werden böse, die Helden sind nicht die Helden, die ihr denkt, die sie sind, sondern sie haben auch
eine böse Seite in sich. Ich finde das Beispiel
Bambi nur so falsch.
Aber fressen Enten
Frösche? Du bist noch dabei.
Also ist das ein...
Aber ich meine, vor allem bei Donald Duck, es gibt ja
den bösen Duck, es gibt ja seinen Onkel.
Dagobert. Dagobert, du kannst
ja sagen, Donald will...
Worauf freuen wir? Worauf freuen wir? Donald Duck will Kermit kriegen. Fliegen, fliegen. E.T. dürfte gar nicht fliegen. Kriegen, Donald will seines Onkels Geld kriegen. Okay, ein bisschen holprig, ein bisschen kurze Verspätung, aber Donald Duck will Gesetze biegen oder sowas. Ich weiss es nicht genau. Auch nicht schlecht. Irgendwie sowas. Wer hat die Hamilton-Übersetzung eigentlich geschrieben? Hat doch... Das war ich, ja. Wir hätten die Saga Express-Übersetzung schreiben sollen. Ja, das stimmt. Unser Angebot hiermit wäre übrigens, ich weiss nicht, ob wir uns ein Disco-Fizzer haben in den letzten Minuten schon, aber ich würde gerne die Übersetzung von dem nächsten Teil, weil die Frauen sind immer noch Wagen, die nicht eigentlichständig fahren können, ja, also vielleicht wäre mein Angebot, wir machen die dritte Fassung und da übersetzen wir dann den geilen Song, wäre das was? Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee, wie würdest, ja, ich kann dir gerne dann, ich assistiere dir gerne, also ich wäre gerne der Assistent, ich bringe dann Herr Tietze so dann die Korrespondenz. Das klingt so, als würdest du nicht arbeiten wollen.
Nee, nee, das stimmt nicht, das gehört ja auch dazu, ich bringe dir so die Korrespondenz, ich bin der Wagen zu deiner Lok.
Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich bin der Bremswagen zu deiner Lok, wenn du verstehst, was ich meine.
Du bist mein Bremswagen, ich verstehe, glaube ich, was du meinst, aber das klingt wir nicht arbeiten wollen, sondern mehr so Snacks im Raum essen wollen und nicht mitarbeiten wollen. Nee, ich fühle mich gut dabei, dir zur Hand zu gehen. Als sagen, da haben Sie leider einen Fehler gemacht, Herr Tietze. Sie haben leider einen riesigen Blutfleck auf dem Skript. Ich weiss nicht, was da passiert ist, aber ist was... Sorry, ich schwitze Blut und Wasser.
Oh, Sie nehmen das richtig ernst. Sie ist ein richtiger Held, Herr Tietzer. Niemand hätte das so umschreiben können wie Sie. Der Side Express von einer merkwürdigen, komischen Song- und Tanzgeschichte wird zu einem grossen Klassiker werden durch Sie. Das würde ich den ganzen Tag machen, dich loben.
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Botschaft.
Manchmal muss man auch der Wagen sein.
Das stimmt, ja. Verstehst du, du darfst nicht...
Problematisch, weil die Frauen können nicht zum Lok werden.
Man müsste die Lok umbauen.
Ja, aber man macht so Züge mit zwei Loks, hinten und vorne so.
Ich fahr von Stuttgart nach Hamm und du bringst mich von Hamm nach Stuttgart. Oder man bringt die auf den Berg, aber dann können sie alleine runterfahren. Es ist schwer, aus dieser Zugmetapher rauszukriegen, es ist schwierig. Vor allem, was macht man aus, die Reservierungen werden nicht angezeigt, was bedeutet das für eine Beziehung? Was ist mit geänderte Wagenreihung, Gessau?
Ja, genau.
Was ist mit Stellwerkstellwerkstaten?
Ihr seid schon immer die Figuren sagen, Schatz, wir haben eine geänderte Wagenreihung.
Was heißt das? Willst du dich scheiden lassen?
Ja.
Schatz, du zeigst mir schon seit Monaten nicht mehr die Reservierung an.
Wann hast du mir das letzte Mal die Reservierung angezeigt, Schatz?
Wann? Wann ging das letzte Mal die Klimaanlage? Wir sind hier im Ruheabteil, bitte schweigen. Das sagst du jedes Mal, aber ich respektiere es. Ich respektiere es. Nice. Es ist der erste Draft, es ist der erste Draft für eine dritte Show. Side Express muss sich weiterentwickeln, es kommt immer wieder Neues hinzu. Ich finde das gut.
Ich finde das sehr wichtig.
Ich finde es gut, wir sollten das machen, immer neu umschreiben.
Genau wie hat China nicht Fight Club umgeschrieben?
In China darf ja der Original Fight Club
nicht mehr laufen, weil das Ende
zu anarchisch-Revoluzzer-mäßig
ist und deswegen ist das
Ende von Fight Club in China jetzt ohne
Scheiss, er wird glaube ich
geschnappt. Moment, und das haben die dann neu nachgedreht oder was? Ja. Die müssen neu das Ende drehen oder sie mussten so aus dem bestehenden Zähnen. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Aber ich dachte mir, das wäre voll geil, das mit anderen Filmen zu machen. Einfach andere Filme, die einem nicht gefallen, wo das Ende einfach zu lang ist oder nicht irgendwo hinführt oder das Ende scheiße ist.
Ja, kann man einfach umändern.
Ich denke mir bei manchen aktuellen Filmen auch so, die müssen...
Aber Scholz schweigt.
Okay.
Scholz könnte ja...
Okay, Titelseite Stefan Tietze erhebt Anklage gegen China-Zensur.
Ja, China macht Filme besser. Leider sind die Pressefotos so erbärmlich lächerlich, weil Stefan Tietze anscheinend wie ein Zugverkleidet auf einer 30 Jahre alten Zugstrecke stehend nicht ernst genommen werden kann. Aber mit ganz finsteren Blick sagt, aber Scholz schweigt. Weird. Ohren betäubendes Schweigen. Wie immer. Ja,
schwierig. Aber ich habe manchmal auch zwei stehenden, also ich habe Riesenprobleme, Plots zu
verstehen bei Filmen, immer. Ich schaue Filme an und komme aus dem Kino und oh, wer hat es dir
gefallen? Und meine ehrliche Antwort ist, ich habe nichts verstanden. Nichts verstanden. War das ein
Flashback? War die erste Hälfte in der Zukunft? Nee, okay, dann habe ich gar nichts verstanden. Ja, ich mochte diese antichronologische Erzählweise. Hä, wieso gab es das? Ja, wieso, es war doch einfach komplett linear erzählt. Ja, okay, dann schaue ich mir noch mal. Alles klar, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Und deswegen würde ich in einem Landleben, wo man weiss, die Kinofilme werden zensiert, würde mir das total helfen, weil ich mir denke, ja, ich habe es noch nicht verstanden,
bei der es Ende falsch geschnitten wurde.
Oder komplizierte Filme werden umgeschnitten.
Ja, genau.
Wie Tenet. Es war auch toll, mit dir Tenet zu gucken.
Der beste Film, um im Kino zu sein, um über Fragen der Augen zu gucken.
Weil ich, ich verstehe den Plot auch nicht, aber ich tue so, als hätte ich es verstanden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen uns.
Und auch wieder, wenn ich in einem Kino arbeiten würde, ich würde als Prank einmal Tenet falschrum zeigen. Einfach so, einfach falschrum zeigen, weil die Leute schauen sich's an, die haben gehört, ja, der ist verwirrend, der ist komisch, der Film. Und man sitzt einfach drin drei Stunden lang und dann so, ja. Du hast trotzdem danach die Leute so sagen, aber das Pacing war mega geil und so. Ja, einfach klasse und die Musik, du kannst nichts falsch machen. Eigentlich musst du, wenn du einen Film machst, schon davor das Image haben, dass deine Filme total verwirrend sind und irgendwie total künstlerisch oder so, du kannst dann nichts mehr falsch machen. Du kannst eigentlich nicht mehr schlecht davon kommen, weil die Leute einfach sagen, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben, du hast es nur nicht verstanden. Du hast Christopher Nolan nicht verstanden. Die Szene mit den Gummibärchen, wo alles geschmolzen ist und dann war das Bild die ganze Zeit. Das war die Werbung. Ach so. Und dann, wo diese ganzen Buchstaben übers Bild gefahren sind die ganze Zeit. Verkehrt herum. Was war da los? Das ist schwierig. Schwer zu verstehen. Was ist ein Keygrip? Was ist ein Keygrip? Den habe ich nie gesehen im Film. Nie habe ich den gesehen. Sehr gut. Ich glaube, wir können hier ein bisschen mehr mit dem Publikum. Lass uns mal ein bisschen spazieren. Draußen auf den Plakaten steht nämlich, dass man ein bisschen spazieren geht. Draußen auf den Plakaten steht, dass es ein Mittendrin sein-Musical. Man soll das machen. Ich habe letztens von einem Trainer gehört, dass man gar nicht unbedingt ins Fitnessstudio muss oder so. Es reicht, dass man spaziert. Es reicht, dass man spazierend unterwegs ist. So, wenn ich's hier mal machen, oh, guck mal, hier können wir stehen bleiben an diesem herrlichen See. Ach, guck dir das an, ist das nicht schön? Hi. Ah, toll, schöne Wohnung auch hier, ne? Schön, aber teuer, habe ich gehört. Ja, hier ist teuer. Ja. Ich meine, die Urlaub machen, schön, aber wohnen, nein. Wohnen würde ich hier nicht wollen, neuck dir mal diese armen Menschen an. Da würde ich auch nicht wohnen wollen. Nee, ach nee, lass uns mal schneller gehen. Das ist eine schlechte Gegend hier. Das ist eine schlechte Gegend hier. Hier liegt verbotene Schmuggelware auf dem Boden. Mitten auf den Gleisen liegt Pico-Balla. Sorry, wer kann nur bis hierhin werfen? Wer war es? Wer hat versucht, Haribo ... Da ganz oben! Hey, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Wow, das ist eine gute Strecke. Das ist eine gute Strecke. Erste schnell, hier ist es gelandet. Du hast vor allem den einzigen Bereich getroffen, wo du niemanden verletzt. Das ist schon beeindruckend. Und auch, wo niemand anderen es klauen kann. Ja, das stimmt. Niemand hat sich getraut. Ihr habt geguckt, ob der Arm lang genug ist. Ihr habt geguckt, ob das geht. Aber hier eure Steißbeine, geht's gut? Alle Steißbeine noch intakt? Man ist so nah an den Leuten dran, ey. Wahnsinn. Normalerweise ist es immer so eine graue Masse. Und jetzt sieht man hier, dass es einfach Leute sind, die hergekommen sind, die mit dem Auto hierher gefahren sind.
Es ist so fucking unruhig.
Ja, lass uns mal schnell wieder weitergehen, bitte.
Ich muss die teilen?
Was ist die teilen?
Nichts teile ich hier, gar nicht.
Doch wir machen die auf und dann geben wir die rum.
Oh ja, das finde ich ein schöneres Gefühl.
Halt mal kurz.
Okay.
Hallo, ich bin Stefan Tietze.
Ich habe einen richtig guten Modegeschmack, findet ihr nicht? Ich bin immer als erstes bei der Location, da beschwere ich mich, dass Florentin zu spät kommt, obwohl wir dann doch noch zwei Stunden überlegen müssen, was wir machen und dann gar nichts machen. Oh, ich teile natürlich auch meine Süßigkeiten, weil ich nicht so verfressen bin wie Florentin. So, jetzt hör mal auf, du Arschloch. Okay, sorry then. Erstens habe ich einen guten Modus, zweitens, kommst du immer zu spät, wie weit das wird diesen Bereich nicht verlassen, jeder nur eins, jeder nur eins, wir überprüfen das, Jesus Christ, wie viel hast du genommen? Zwei, da wird nicht geteilt, brecht sein Steißbein, auf ihn, nach hinten mit ihm, auf ihn, jetzt können wir noch eruieren, wie viele in so einer Packung drin sind, weil wir wissen, wie weit es geht. Guck mal, wir lernen hier Dinge. Heroieren, habe ich auch gerade gelernt von dir. Wir können heroieren. Aber kennst du das, es gibt ein Wort dafür, wenn man checkt, das, weil es ist ja wirklich so, normalerweise hat man so ein Licht in der Fresse bei anderen Theatern und sieht halt dann niemanden. Und wenn man gerade vorbeigeht, gucken einen alle mit grossen Augen an und sind auch Menschen mit Komplexität. Und dieses Gefühl nennt man to saunder. Kennst du das? Das ist das Bewusstsein, es gibt ein Wort dafür, es ist das Bewusstsein, es ist das, ja, Mr. Heroin. Es ist das Bewusstsein, dass andere Menschen auch Leben mit einer krassen Komplexität haben, die sie in dein Leben führt. Das wird zu erklären. Du willst sagen, dass Menschen nicht nur Waggons sind, sondern auch Lokomotiven? Männer, ja. Okay, was dann. Ich glaube, dann verstehe ich, was du meinst. Die letzten Reihen, die Armen. So, wo ist Pico Waller? Wie viele von euch rechnen sich jetzt schon aus, die Chance, ob sie noch was kriegen oder nicht? So, wie viel werden da drin sein in so einer Haribo-Packung? Sagen wir mal 80, eins, zwei, drei, vier. Ich zähle in zwei, zwei, vier, sechs, acht, sechs. Aber spannend, dass quasi der Block entschieden hat, dass es im Block bleibt. Quasi, also dieser kleine Lokalpartietismus. Hätte ich gedacht, wäre eine Reihenfrage. Nee, Blockfrage. Aber es wird nach hinten gegeben. Ja, man will nicht aufstehen. Wir haben offiziell bewiesen, dass diese Teilenpackungen nicht funktionieren, weil man letzten Endes dann doch nicht teilen will. Es ist Magie, die hier passiert. Ist es das Spannendste, was er jemals beobachtet? Vor allem, es steht wahrscheinlich draußen ganz gross, man darf keine eigenen Lebensmittel mitbringen oder so, und wir zelebrieren das hier seit zehn Minuten, dass irgendjemand das geschmuggelt und nicht sehr weit geworfen hat, ehrlich gesagt. Ich will es nicht, es ist schwer zu sagen mit der Höhe. Ich denke immer, und ich weiß nicht, ob es ja auch geht, ich denke immer, wenn man höher ist, kann man auch weiter werfen. Aber das ist schlicht nicht wahr. Aber ich denke es jedes Mal. Ich stehe auf so einer Klippe und denke mir, Alter, ich werfe bis zum Horizont. Und dann mache ich solche mit. Nein, das ist einfach falsch. Aber ich will das nicht glauben. Ja, ich glaube es gerade wieder. Stell dir vor, du stehst auf dem Empire State Building und du hast ein Pennystück in der Hand. Andere Frage, ob wir damit jemand umbringen können, dazu kommen wir gleich. Aber du wirfst weit. Ich denke, ich könnte damit irgendwie bis in diesen See reinwerfen oder so. Naja, aber das Ding ist ja, es fällt ja nicht so hin, also es fällt ja nicht gerade runter. Wenn du normal weit wirfst jetzt, der Einfallwinkel ist ja schräg. Das heißt doch, im Unkenschluss... Deine Worte, deine Worte, sie sind Zucker in meinen Ohren, aber sie entsprechen nicht der Wahrheit. Doch, doch, doch, hör auf, hör zu. Was du sagst, deine Worte sagen ja, doch die Realität sagt nein. Muss die Realität immer so hart sein, muss, was ich mir vorstelle, immer im Kopf zerstört werden. Von der Realität ... Verdammt, warum reinziehen, die es auf dem Kopf war? Ja, das war Florentin Will mit seinem Polislam. Komm jetzt, Julia Engelmann. Dankeschön. Und jetzt wieder Julia Engelmann. Aber ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt. Ich glaube, man denkt immer noch in Papierflieger-Dimensionen. Weil Papierflieger von weit oben, der ist in Kanada. Also keine Chance, weg. Aber wenn du wirfst, und das dachte wahrscheinlich unsere Zuschauerin hier vorne auch, die dachte, ich kann so weit werfen, weil ich bin ja richtig hoch.
Nein, ist falsch, ist einfach falsch.
Peinlich.
Wir haben schon dafür gesorgt, dass wir die reichen Leute uns bewerfen können, dass ihr uns nicht zu nahe kommen könnt.
Die Packung ist weg, glaube ich. Mir wurde übrigens auch ein Twix dahingelegt.
Oh, ich stund' klar, dass hier reingeschmuggelt wurde.
Von dir, vielen Dank. So, jetzt möchte ich nämlich mal herausfinden, wie weit ich werfen kann. Oh! Nachteil ist ein Twix und der ist hart. Schützt eure Steisbeine, Freunde. Jetzt wird es gefährlich. Das kannst du nicht machen. Weil ich habe nämlich auch gelernt, ich lese mich dann ein in Themen und ich habe gelernt, dass 45 Grad Winkel der beste ist, um Weite zu erzielen. Fürs Protokoll, ich bin weiter als 10 Meter entfernt, ich bin nicht mitschuldig. Ich habe 40 Minuten Jura studiert, so viel weiß ich. 10 Meter ist die Grenze. Also wie beim Eishockey, alle müssen jetzt das Twix angucken, weil es kann zu schwierigen Verletzungen kommen. Okay, Achtung. Oh, direkt auf Steissballen! Hat sie mir gefangen? Nice, nice, guten Aufmerksamkeit. Und nun Florentin Will aus Deutschland mit seinem, äh, Sprung, äh. Es fehlen drei Hundertstel zu Gold. Die Finnin Clara Hechnetenen hat bereits Silber in der Tasche. Wir drücken ihm die Daumen, er kommt aus Ebersberg bei Berchtesgad. Er nimmt Anlauf und läuft herunter. Das sieht gut aus, das sieht gut aus. Er rollt und rutscht, er rutscht so weit, so weit war niemand. Und es ist Gold, das ist Gold, Gold für Florentin Will. Es ist unglaublich, er läuft los, er hat immer noch Kraft, das haben wir noch nie gesehen. Ich mache diesen Job schon seit zwei, zwanzig Jahren und das haben wir noch nicht gesehen. Leute drehen sich auf ihren Stühlen, um ihn weiter sehen zu können, das ist unglaublich. Er hat sich die Herzen aller ZuschauerInnen erspielt, Florentin Will bei der Sportart, bei der nur zwei Menschen mitmachen. Dankeschön. Yes. Aber hast du dich verletzt? Steißbein? Verstaucht? Geht's gut. Das ist die große Kunst. Das hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert, wesentlich mehr Spaß gemacht, als es, als ich dachte. Ja. Ich kann es empfehlen. Ja. Ich habe mal als Kind
mein Steißbein gebrochen, das ist mir eingefallen. Mir ist ein Bett gefallen. Jetzt kommen wir an den Punkt, wo ich zugeben muss, dass ich nicht weiß, was ein Steißbein ist. Erklärst du uns? Schlüsselbein, meine ich auch.
Jesus. Also, Schlüsselbein ist das hier, ne? Wie fucking faul sind Anatomen eigentlich? Ich meine, die haben, ja okay, die beiden lassen uns Bein nennen, und das
Vielen Dank. Jesus. Also, Schlüsselbein ist das hier, ne? Wie fucking faul sind Anatomen eigentlich? Ich meine, die haben, ja okay, die beiden lassen uns Bein nennen und das hier oben, Schulterbein, Nasbein, haben wir schon, Schlüsselbein, einfach alles im Bein. Ja, nee, also das ist das Schlüsselbein hier oben und Steissbein ist das, wo du dich jetzt raussetzt. Achtung, da.
Alter, das ist so glatt hier. Falls ihr euch denkt, krass wie schnell die fahren. Nee, ist einfach glatt. Die geben eigentlich gar nicht so viel Gas.
Oh, guck mal, dein Scheinwerfer hat sich verloren. Da ist der Lichtmann eingepennt.
Haha, die kann fliehen. Nein, hört mich! Nein!
Das ist meine Chance zu fliehen. Eingepennt. Okay, zum Schreiben. Oh. Ah, nein. Jetzt ist meine Chance. Ich kann fliegen. Nein! Ich liebe einen Gruß auch an die Zuhörer da draußen, die gerade nur die Podcast-Folge lernen. Es ist nicht so, als würden wir mehr verstehen, was hier passiert. Das stimmt. Alter, ich bin so aus Atem. Ich war aber schon schnell, oder? Also das ist schon angebracht. Das ist angebracht, der Level an Erschöpfung. Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt, das ist okay, oder? Das ist okay. Ist okay, ist voll okay. Hey, es ist voll okay. Es ist nicht deine Schuld. Es ist nicht deine Schuld. Es ist nicht deine Schuld. 30 Meter weine jetzt. Es ist nicht deine Schuld. Dieser brennende Schmerz in den Lungen. Hast du nicht Good Will Hunting geguckt? Es ist nicht deine Schuld. Okay. Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, warum er dann weint. Das ist, weil du eine Lokomotive bist und kein Waggon. Deswegen kannst du das nicht verstehen. Aber dieser brennendeenschmerz in den Lungen ist völlig normal für 60 Meter, oder? Ja, gut, ja. Das Problem ist, sie haben fünf Linge. Oh nein. Weil jede Drillinge haben jeweils, zwei von denen haben jeweils noch einen Zwilling. Zwei meiner Drillinge haben jeweils einen Zwilling. Ja. Na, pass auf, dann machen wir folgendes. Dann nenne ich die Drillinge Tick, Trick, Track und dann aber zu Track und dann zu Trick und Track, dann noch, also wir haben Tick, Trick, Track und dann Tick, Dick, sagen wir mal und Trick, Drick. So verstehst du, so haben wir zweier Pärchen und eine dreier Gruppe. Okay, so machen wir es. Hand drauf, Hand drauf, Arzt. Herr Weber. So machen wir es. Herr Weber, das ist das weirdeste Musical, das uns jemals gepitcht wurde. Nein, die Leute werden es lieben. Jeder kennt das doch, wenn du einen Drillingsgeschwister hast und einen Zwillingsgeschwister. Wir nehmen lieber das Musik hier mit den singenden Zügen. Okay, wie ihr wollt, kein Problem. Ich habe aber auch so ein bisschen so ein gewisses Tabaluga-TV-Gefühl, muss ich sagen. Als wollten mir diese leuchtenden Punkte irgendwas sagen, weil der hier ist nicht ganz in der Mitte. Der ist nicht in der Mitte, ist hier der Schatz. Diese Folge ist für Leute zuhause so fucking weird, wir hätten das filmen. Vielleicht gut, dass wir es nicht gefilmt haben. Ich habe genug Videospiele gespielt, um zu wissen, dass hier irgendwas machbar ist. Man baut nicht einfach so Lampen in den Boden ein. Stell du Stell mal ganz nach außen und ich mich ganz nach außen. Da auf der anderen Seite. Okay, also. Und dann müssen wir gleichzeitig Schritte machen, aber nur auf den Punkten, okay? Also der Boden ist Lava, aber ausser halt die Punkte. Okay, nur auf den Punkten und eins. Nein, wir, wir fangen nochmal an, wir müssen nochmal anfangen. Wir müssen nochmal anfangen. Okay, wir dürfen nur auf die Punkte. Eins, zwei und drei. Das ist viel schwieriger für mich. Da war was. Tschu, tschu.
Tschuuu.
Keiner kann es besser als die Dampflocken. Hier ist doch was.
Der Geist des Musicals.
Er muss hier sein, wir haben sein Rätsel gelüftet.
Wo ist er?
Ist er hier?
Der Starlight Express?
Ist er wirklich hier?
War er die ganze Zeit schon hier? Hat er uns mit Süssigkeiten beworfen?
Er ist hier. Vielen Dank, Leute, vielen Dank an den Geist von Starlight Express, vielen Dank an diese wehre Show.
Niemand wird verstehen, was heute Abend passiert ist.
Vielen Dank an das Theater, das wir hier sein durften. Es ist so großartig.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Dankeschön, liebe Leute.
Oh, Achtung!
Yes! Fuck yes! Es ist so befriedigend. Ihr werdet nie erfahren, wie es das anfühlt.
Wir sind das Podcast-Uvo. Das war Sterbbar Siebner.
Vielen Dank fürs Rumkommen. Das war Florian in den Rennen. Vielen Dank für alles.
Und wir heben ab, gemeinsam.
Vielen, vielen Dank, Schalter. Vielen Dank. Ist jede Story echt? Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Heide.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch.
Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta.